[Music]
consistency is key
consistency is the challenge
these were the words that were scribbled
across the mirror of my friend rajiv's
bedroom
these were the words of someone so
dedicated to self-improvement
that they held power within them
four months back rajiv and i sat in a
cafe in singapore
where we were both living at the time we
had just finished a workout class
and i remember rajiv looking up at me
with a big smile across his face
and sharing that he had just taken steps
towards achieving one of his biggest
dreams
to become a fitness instructor
in the months prior i had seen rajiv
dedicate himself to a healthy lifestyle
working out consistently eating
healthily
and the effect showed not just on his
body but in his spirit
his exuberant energy inspired me to
chase one of my similar dreams
to become a spin instructor and so that
day
we set off we shared programming with
each other we sent music
and ultimately we did it when the time
came
we proudly attended one another's
classes
and let me tell you no one lit up a
studio like rajiv did
my world shook to its core the day that
we lost rajiv
i had lost a close friend and with him
my belief he was on his way towards
achieving his fullest potentials
and in an instant it was all taken away
i had heard about experiencing grief
before
the helplessness the sadness the denial
the stages but i was unprepared for the
chaos that followed
and i was unprepared to face that chaos
alone
for some reason talking about grief is
taboo which
is hard for me to comprehend because
it's one of the most
human and universal experiences that
we'll have in life
whether we like it or not every one of
us will
or has lost someone that we loved
so why then do we tiptoe around it
why not open up because in my experience
trying to confine it or control it
doesn't work
my grief is everywhere and i'm learning
to live with it
to truly live in this chaos
so today let's open up and let's talk
about the experience of loss
then let's talk about what it's like to
experience another person's grief
until finally we meet this moment
and learn how to ride through the chaos
together
after rajiv passed i remember walking to
his apartment
the canal sparkling off on my right and
bars on my left where we used to watch
tennis together
i remember a distinct ringing in my ears
and the whole world
muted around me
attention formed within me on the one
hand i wanted to smile and reminisce
about our tennis rivalry
i'm a federer fan he was an adult fan
and on the other i wanted to cry out in
desperation
why him how could this have happened
how will things ever be the same
as i entered his apartment the silence
provided answers
things won't ever be the same
it's hard to conceptualize loss but the
kubler-ross model tells us that there
are five stages of grief
denial anger bargaining
depression and acceptance
this sounds like a pretty nice framework
all i have to do is work through each
stage of grief like a twisted video game
and ultimately i'll be fine
well dark humor aside i do think that
these stages are helpful
these are feelings that i've had deep in
my morning
but the notion that there are set stages
to work through
or a path to move down doesn't resonate
with me
the so-called cycle of grief actually
felt like a roller coaster
and i couldn't and honestly still can't
see each drop
and each turn at times i feel like i'm
strapped in
and i can't get off and at other times i
feel unbuckled
like i'm going to fly out at any time
the waves of emotion are random and
sporadic
tearing up in an accounting class crying
on my way to get a coveted test
or laughing and reminiscing in a spin
class
so what's it called when instead of
moving through each stage of grief
i'm bouncing from anger to depression
to bargaining to acceptance
why then two years later do i feel that
second stage of grief
anger that i'm standing on this stage
and rajiv is not
well it's called chaos and it's messy
and it's uncontrolled but it's human
i returned to work four days after rajiv
passed
and my wonderful team welcomed me back
with compassion
well wishes and pity
you know the kind the slight tilt of the
head
the concerned furl of the brow the
hunching of the mouth
i dreaded every single interaction
wondering if these pity stares would
ever stop
despite the good intentions of my
colleagues and despite the condolence
texts and the heart emojis from my
friends
i felt alone in my sorrow
these displays of love were kind and
were caring
and i get it we care so much about our
friends and our loved ones
that we want to say the right thing or
send the right text
but while we're deliberating the
grieving are grieving alone
we stay on the surface water looking
down into the dark
deep murky waters afraid to pull our
loved ones back under
but in doing so we prevent them a chance
to express
their needs whether that be distance an
expression of sorrow
or laughing and reminiscing in fond
memories
so what do we do how do we grieve
and how do we support how do we ride
through this chaos
well grievers you cannot and should not
hold yourselves to feeling some
certain type of way you don't need to be
in a specific stage of grief
as author megan devine tells us survival
and grief
and building a life alongside grief
comes with it a willingness
to bear witness to both yourself
and to those who find themselves living
a life that they didn't see coming
we have to be honest with ourselves what
stage of grief am i feeling today
where am i in this chaos
and then if we can we need to be honest
with those around us
as they tiptoe around can we ground them
by telling them what we need and what we
don't
and supporters you don't need to say the
right thing or help cheer us up
you don't need to feel my sorrow i would
never wish that upon anyone
but it means the world to me that you
recognize it and that you sit with me as
i experience it
megan devine continues on to say that
some things can't be fixed
they can only be carried
will you sink into that chaos and help
carry that weight of sorrow
will you be there consistently
ready and patient no matter where the
that person who is grieving is at
because that perhaps is the most
generous thing that you can do
loss is inevitable and grief
is eventual but when we meet it i hope
that we will be brave as grievers
i hope that we'll hang in there
i hope that we will feel our feelings
and express our needs
and supporters i hope that you will
choose to carry that weight
and be consistent in your support for
your loved ones
as we ride through this chaos together i
hope that we'll remember what rajiv
taught me
and now you consistency
is key consistency
is the challenge